energy we use it every day without even
noticing at every moment of our lives is
fair but how can we be sure that energy
will always be there 24/7 around half
the energy we use is produced in Europe
the other half is imported from abroad
for these imports we pay at least 1
billion euros every single day what if
what if this money could be used in
Europe we could produce our own energy
and become more energy efficient
this would make us less dependent on
foreign supplies in fact we can make
this happen how by engaging together in
the European energy security strategy
let's see what can be done fast save
energy
second produce more local energy
especially renewable electricity third
make it easier to transport gas and
electricity around Europe 4th find
different ways and routes to import
energy build good relations with
suppliers and producers and last but not
least have common goals when negotiating
with other countries in other words
speak with one voice
the European energy security strategy
let's engage for a reliable and
affordable European energy